lukas attention pour donner la météo
mais d'abord et l'agité pour la saison
social
vu les réactions des syndicats et d'une
manière générale de la politique
économique
maintenant il est possible de genre et
de quatre d'entre eux voir quelle sera
la taille de la rentrée sera créée
autour de dossiers le pétrole elle doit
renégocier le prix que d'être end
supplémentaire à payer 18 milliard en
plus cette année justifie t'elle un taux
d'inflation supérieure à 10%
premier ministre affirme que non quelle
polémique se poursuit grâce un deuxième
volet le plus important parti qui fut
portefeuille défendre et c'est le
pouvoir d'achat après les récentes aux
carburants et les présenter et surtout
l'augmentation les réactions sont
arrivés en cascade successivement elle
n'aurait rallye de la cdp en hébergement
pour force ouvrière a lancé un
avertissement au gouvernement
si vous dépassez sartenais buts acquise
il faut s'attendre à une crise sociale
peut être dangereux
hier il a exigé l'ouverture
les cadres de la cgc par la bonne jambe
nue ce sont de rigueur pour préparer une
riposte aux communes et enfin dernière
en date la culture georges marchais
éduquer à s'allier au diable pour
combattre la politique sans dire qu'il
est temps de les calmer et sur les
contrats l'intérêt de la nation et
l'unité très vital par exemple patent
mais des divergences importantes entre
les centrales syndicales
alors avant de lancer une autre inconnue
et recompté les singles à bâle en
espérant que le rattrapage du pouvoir
d'achat se révélera athènes mobilisateur
de son côté le gouvernement même s'il
affirme que les français
cette insécurité intérêt cela il a déjà
exceptionnel c'est nous les connaîtrons
la rentrée méfiez-vous la ministre du
travail qui était notre invité à midi a
expliqué qu'il y aurait probablement une
rue vannerie scolaire n'était pas là il
fallait renforcer l'édifice social
et la politique de solidarité sociale
monsieur mitterrand personnalités du
parti socialiste cette décision
l'entrée les sauterelles et patrice des
émissions issues de la radio le matin
sur le communiqué du conseil des
ministres sur le respect prévu at elle
respecté là bas alors il s'agit à
l'évidence d'un coup de semonce un
avertissement sur le territoire j'avais
vu que le temps de cours sur le parti
le secret le ps appelle la mie câline
assemblée nationale la prostitution pour
ce 8 mai et d'une amende de 10 millions
seulement
on est à cinq personnes
la bouche est leur pays l'irak a accusé
le gouvernement de la mousse n a jamais
ici est à cincy jamais pourtant d'irak
doit se garder à gauche à droite avait
bon appétit
à gauche c'est la série la tène serré
qu'à l'origine du dernier tango à drac
et sa révolution islamique
images de guerre en irak merci la
muscade milliers aux portes de batna est
encore dans la crise n'est pas seulement
hier depuis la révolution iranienne il
s'agira considérés comme des potentiels
majoritaire en irak actuel des
socialistes contre
il n'est pas étranger quelle est la part
aux canaries en ya eu crime de miracle
doit être un dernier block
voilà comment la presse en irak présent
pas répondu
un auteur un plaignant
à la suite des récents accords signés ce
qui d'ailleurs n'exclut pas complètement
dans le cadre global le danger d'un
contenu pour le proche orient une région
où les états unis le président du
parlement de la première sera lu avec ap
selon lui aujourd'hui
comme carter serait qu'en est il
jusqu'où va se maintenir et l ain
savourer une série intitulée par elle
même
d'exagérer label de son gazole a décidé
de partir un homme profondément pour
jamais de jallet sur celles à la maison
blanche et noire
il est en bonne santé
je suis aussi désormais de se classer
nouvelle campagne qui tient aujourd'hui
dans une ruine
bien sûr
sérieux c'est aujourd'hui un iphone la
monnaire ne fait peut-être pas il fit
and square avant que l'histoire de mie
câline dana les ascensions dans les
années économiques mais dit elle les
dirigeants prétendent au temps de sa
splendeur où le surnommer le chilien
glaciale selon nous plus important
défilé ni clerck les journaux américains
comme mots-clés prochaine la carrière de
crimes de la mafia maquille pas fiable
ma carte tout-venant a répété l'un des
financiers de la masia place à la
musique du cynisme il aurait blanchi
cette année honneur
la laque ou quand jean denat est l'homme
de la norme dans ses affaires internes
ou troisième mortiers maternité mais n'y
a ni société
nikon nous sommes auxquelles il est
important de la campagne électorale du
président charles l'euphorie
pas cher non seulement sur quelques
années simonac toujours conférences
notamment sur la renaissance seulement
aux états unis mais aussi en italie
sinden est impliqué dans les procès en
cascade
ces deux là on savait beaucoup trop pour
les deux sont friands c'est la nationale
politique déconnecté de la vie politique
en italie
il disparaît quelques jours après
l'assassinât d'un parent n'a pas ces
lettres de jeunes ministres sur les
conséquences si la teneur ou de se plier
il ne pèse sur nos partenaires sont
bloqués depuis 18 ans garçons à miss
paris quinze personnes et 10 millions il
a passé la course dans les deux sens
avec ses rangées par défaut
quelque 80 il y avait hier c'est
aujourd'hui à un gain facile d'arriver
premier tour bien un deuxième le cas de
la messe et la cale 2 l'île états unis
en ce moment là c'est la dernière mode
tél
la première pratique
quelques mois à travers toute la nuit le
matin
très bien
on ne sent pas une liste de
l'entraînement réservé aux patineurs sur
fond de musique
aujourd'hui vaincre le récuser moins de
réussite
matin
voici le temps en france demain le temps
sera perturbé vers la louisiane que
mutins
les vins sont bien que la tramontane se
lèveront